morning Kay I mean what we've seen in
this report is a shocking compilation of
atrocities that we have heard of and and
seen trickle out of the Central African
Republic over the years of Wagner's
activity there and but it is again
extremely shocking to see it all on
paper to see the witness testimonies
soldiers and militia men trained by
Wagner to commit atrocities against a
civilian population wiping out Villages
cutting off people's fingers
it is just it's it's quite a horrific
read but this is this prototype template
for Wagner in Africa and Central African
Republic specifically is the longest
engagement they've had on the continent
the deal was cut in October 2017 and
came in action in January 2018 when
Russian instructors as Russian
authorities like to call it were sent to
the Central African Republic to support
the military in protecting the
presidency there from rebellions and
since then as you know the last five
years have been brutal and in 2022 a
study showed that the population of 5.6
of Central African Republic's population
died now Wagner is not the only thing at
play there of course but the presence of
Wagner has really worsened the
humanitarian crisis there in a country
that has seen Decades of conflict and
that is what Wagner do on the continent
they exploit existing political issues
fragmentation issues you know within the
civilian population they've got a
there's an exerted effort effort for
propaganda but that isn't just Wagner
that is essentially the the partnership
that Russia has with countries on the
African continent whether it's Mali
whether it's Central African Republic
we've seen it definitely in Mali where
crowds were actually cheering and waving
Russian flags as French troops left and
Wagner came in their place to fight the
counterinsurgency that's been plaguing
Mali for years and that isn't again just
about Wagner it is about deals that are
cut by Russia's foreign minister Sergey
lavrov in which Wagner is a contingent
that is essentially replaceable